ISABELLE OLSSON: Thank you for
coming to listen to the panel
about atoms and bits.
We're a bunch of industrial
designers up here.
First we have Mike Simonian.
He's an award winning designer.
He's on Forbes' 100
Most Creative list.
And he's working at
Google X and trying
to envision successful designs
that have huge business impact.
Then we have lovely
Victoria Slaker,
and she was one of the
founders of Ammunition Design,
and the design team
over there, and has
been a part of designing some
of the most successful consumer
electronics products
on the market today.
Then we have Michael
Ditullo, and he's
the Chief Creative
Officer at Sonic--
MICHAEL DITULLO: Sound United.
ISABELLE OLSSON: Sound
United, I'm sorry.
And he's been wearing a
lot of different hats,
doing everything from
ethnographic research
to marketing and design.
Then we have Maaike
Evers, and she
is also working at Google
X, and is leading design
from the very early stages
that have a huge impact.
And she also co-founded
Mike and Maaike.
And then we have Josh
Morenstein, an old friend
of mine, and he's
co-founded and is
partner of Branch
Design, a young design
studio in San Francisco.
And he's been working on
a bunch of really, really
successful products
on the market.
And then last but
not least, we have
Mitch, Mitchell-- good friend
of mine, too-- Heinrich.
He is a senior
designer, but also
the founder of Design
Kitchen at Google X.
And he is very
excited about going
back to being designer
as prototypers,
as manufacturers, and
really understanding
how things can be
made beautifully.
So to start with, to
kick off this panel,
I asked the panel to
think about, and design
a product that represents
the future of design.
And also something
that incorporates
hardware and software
in an interesting way.
So let's start with Mike.
You chose the Tesla.
How come?
MIKE SIMONIAN: So the reason
I think the Tesla represents
the future of hardware and
software integration, two
reasons.
One is the ability
to receive updates
in a really significant way that
I actually consider to almost
be over the air
hardware updates.
An example is that
the vehicle recently
didn't have to be recalled
because of an issue.
They actually just
did a software update
and it changed the
characteristics of the vehicle
in a way that avoided
an entire recall.
Another example is the way
that the vehicle's ride height
can be adjusted.
They, over the air, can
just change the ride height
of all of their vehicles
at a certain speed
to adjust the vehicle's
performance instantly.
The other approach
I think they've
taken that I think
is really interesting
and relates probably to a lot
of these the products here,
is the ability to learn.
I think that's something that
our products in the future
are really becoming more
and more like humans.
And they're able to learn.
An example in the Tesla is you
can change the ride height.
If you go on to a
certain driveway,
you can adjust the ride height.
And the next day if
you do the same thing,
eventually it
learns that you want
the ride to change the
height right there so you
don't scrape the driveway.
And it will just do
it automatically.
ISABELLE OLSSON: So
I'm curious, whose role
is it to envision
an idea like that?
Is it an industrial designer,
user experience designer?
How do you come up with
something like this?
MIKE SIMONIAN: I think
the only way that happens
is when people step
outside of their roles,
because in traditional
product development,
everything is so siloed that
these ideas don't necessarily
come up unless you're thinking
about the whole system.
And so I think it's everybody
on the project's ability
to just get their hands in
the other people's business,
and come up with these ideas.
ISABELLE OLSSON: So it's
interesting, Victoria,
you chose kind of an old idea.
A little bit of a difference
from Mike's example.
VICTORIA SLAKER: Yeah,
it's a little bit
of a tongue in cheek example.
This is the Phantom
Doormen, and it's something
that we take for granted a lot.
It was actually done in
the '30s by George Devol.
And I chose it because
it represents two trends,
and they're both
around simplicity.
One is this idea of
having the software,
having that sort of interaction.
Sometimes I feel like if we
didn't have these doors built
in the '30s, actually, if
we were to do it today,
there would be this expectation
of having to bring out
your phone to
actually open a door.
So the first part
of it is really
about simplicity
of the interaction
that we're seeing
really happening a lot.
And then the other
one is this idea
of very, very basic objects,
going back and revisiting
things that we thought
were already done,
and starting to look
at them with what
we can do incorporating
software to make them better,
to have them do more things.
An example of that, that
we've done in house,
is a little product called
Leeo, two e's, one o.
And it was kind of
an interesting take.
We'll talk about the
Nest in a little bit,
but what this
client did was say,
well everybody has all
of these smoke detectors
right now in their homes.
How can we make them smarter
with a very simple device?
And what they did was they said,
well, we'll take a night light,
and we'll just have it listen.
And it will listen,
and you can go out,
and it's sitting at home
saying, yeah, yeah, you go out.
I'll just hang out here
and if anything goes wrong
I'll let you know.
And it's such a
simple, simple act,
but it basically
suddenly makes a product
that you really took for
granted much more clever.
And so that's just, for
me, it's about the idea
of simple interactions, not
a lot of onus on the user.
You can walk up to a door or you
can just walk out of your house
and not have to think twice.
And then the other one
is very simple objects
becoming smarter.
ISABELLE OLSSON: So that's
a really great transition
to your project,
which congratulations,
has just launched.
Yeah, tell us about it.
MICHAEL DITULLO: Well,
to riff off of what
Victoria said, so this is
a collection of speakers
that my company just launched
that are all Wi-Fi connected.
An average American home has
three to five speakers in it.
And once all those speakers
are Wi-Fi connected,
there's a lot of different
things you can do.
But to do that you have
to be thinking of those
use cases at the very first
stages of the hardware, right?
It's like you're basically
building a smart home,
but you're building a smart
home kind of LEGO brick
by LEGO brick.
We have to make sure those
bricks will all interconnect
at some point, whether it's
with a Leeo, or with a Nest.
And if you're not
thinking that way,
you'll have these
kind of orphan things
that are in the home that
are smart and yet dumb
at the same time.
And so I think that's a really
interesting part of hardware
development, is we're
predicting where
we think the software
is going to go
but at a much earlier timeline.
And then, eventually, we're
manufacturing those products.
They're on a boat from
Asia and the software
is still being developed.
And the products come into a
warehouse in the United States
and they all get
updated, and then
they get shipped to retail.
And they land in
people's homes and then
they get updated again.
So where the
software you can keep
iterating on and
improving, you have
to build the hardware
to be flexible enough
to be able to do that
from the very onset.
So it's been an
interesting challenge
to reinvent these traditional
products that we take
for granted and bring them
into this larger ecosystem.
ISABELLE OLSSON: So
talking about products
that we take for granted and
then has not, in the past, been
thought through, the Nest
came along and revolutionized
the thermostat.
Maaike, what do
you think about it?
MAAIKE EVERS: Thank you all
for taking all my words out
of my mouth.
But maybe I'd like
to add one more thing
to why I chose this particular
product as an example of where
the future is going to go.
I think this is an excellent
example where Tony Fadell had
a very strong vision,
and was able to corral
a group of very different--
from different backgrounds--
engineers, hardware engineers,
software engineers, EE, design,
web design, app design,
packaging, marketing.
Everything was so
well orchestrated
to come to this moment.
And that such a
difficult thing to do
considering all the
different timelines,
the different backgrounds.
How do you keep that greater
goal, the greater vision
intact through that
difficult process?
Yeah, it's, to me,
a great example
of a well curated
hardware experience that
lives throughout all the
little bits and feelings
that you get from
different touch points
that we have with this product.
ISABELLE OLSSON: So do you
think the role of the designer
in the future is to
wear all these hats?
Or is all that is required a
strong leader in this case?
MAAIKE EVERS: Well,
I actually don't
know how this was
conceived by Tony,
or how strong of
a message he had.
If any of you know,
I'd love to hear it.
But maybe it's a very
strong personality
that has a really
great idea and vision,
and knows exactly where
this is going to land.
Maybe it is just
the right people
coming together and crafting
that story together.
I think designers,
hardware designers
have to start always really
early because hardware
takes so long.
So sometimes these
bits of the DNA
of where this product
is going to end up
are starting at hardware
thinking, or the first concept
phase of thinking.
So sometimes we do
take on that role.
But it gets infused with
many great talented people,
the hardware engineers,
software engineers, everybody.
But yeah, so I'd love
to hear if anybody knows
how this particular product
was developed so well.
But I've seen it done both ways.
Sometimes it's a very
strong vision, up front,
that you get to work with.
Sometimes it's
working with people
to get to that magic idea.
ISABELLE OLSSON: Josh,
and you chose an example
that I think some of us have
a love hate relationship to.
The 3D printing machine.
JOSHUA MORENSTEIN: Yeah.
Well, first, I would
qualify it by saying,
I didn't choose this
particular product
that you're seeing
here because I thought
it was the epitome
of 3D printing,
or whether it's good or
bad industrial designer
or interaction design.
But what they seem
to be talking about--
because it's on Kickstarter
I haven't seen it in person--
is a level of
accessibility that I
don't see in a lot of other
products of this sort.
They sell MakerBot at
Home Depot, and the thing
that we talk about in
our studio all the time,
because we have a couple
of different 3D printers
in the office, and it's
running constantly.
Because for us it's all about
getting stuff in our hands.
About moving from paper, or
sketches, or digital format
to having something
in our hands.
Because ultimately, most
of what we do in the studio
is around that
physical experience.
But my dad goes to Home Depot.
And my dad could buy
a Maker Bot and he
wouldn't know what
to do with it.
But he's got little measuring
tape suspenders, and a pencil
protector, and he has no
idea how to work in 3D CAD.
And these guys, at least, are
talking about the first stages
of bringing that limitation
of getting it from your sketch
into the real world.
I think it's pretty rudimentary.
You could make a label
for your fridge right now,
or maybe you could
do flat jewelry,
which isn't that interesting.
Maybe ultimately I think
it will run out of energy.
But I think it's a first start.
The downside, for me, is that
it puts the design tool that
has been that limitation, it
puts it into everybody's hand.
I had a bunch of
different ideas that I
was going to-- when Isabelle
asked this somewhat difficult,
borderline annoying question
because I couldn't come up
with anything.
Everything kind of had
a good and a bad side.
I was like, god, I'm
such a negative person.
But the bad side
of this is that it
puts design and the making of
objects into anybody's hands.
And the question I
was asking myself was,
should it be in anybody's hands?
I think most of us, if
not all of us are trained,
and we have an expertise.
There's a permanence
in objects when
it comes to industrial
design that has implications,
cultural implications, certainly
ecological implications.
And so my thought was, if
we can all make things,
should we all be making things?
Should we be prototyping stuff?
Yes.
Should we be producing stuff?
I don't know.
I'm not allowed to fly an
airplane with passengers on it,
so should anybody be allowed
to just go out and make
objects and mass produce things?
So that was sort of the
balance I was thinking.
So it is a good and bad side
of the future of design.
MICHAEL DITULLO: Can I
riff off that for a second?
ISABELLE OLSSON: Yeah.
MICHAEL DITULLO: Because we were
talking backstage about this,
and I think it's interesting
because everybody in this room
has the ability to write
a novel on the thing
that you're typing on.
And I haven't written
any novels yet.
And so just because
you have a tool
doesn't mean you will use it.
MAAIKE EVERS: In that way.
MICHAEL DITULLO: Or you might
try to start writing that novel
and be like, you
know, I suck at this.
I'm going to go to the
store and buy a novel.
And you might try to design
something and 3D print it,
and you might like,
yeah, you know what?
No.
JOSHUA MORENSTEIN:
Yeah, that's true.
MAAIKE EVERS: I mean, I see
it more as owning a drill.
Everybody should have a drill.
Everybody should be able
to fix their own stuff.
And this is another
version of that.
Everybody should be able
to make things for whatever
reasons that they need
to have it around.
MITCH HEINRICH: I
also think that you
would think that it would
actually just elevate
good design, because people
would realize that it's hard.
Once this tool is in
everybody's hands,
and they realize that
they're unable to create
that iPhone on their 3D
printer, and that they
can't hit that
level of fidelity,
and that level of polish.
That they realize, OK.
It actually puts you in a
better light as a designer.
JOSHUA MORENSTEIN: You're right.
This is going to
make me look amazing.
ISABELLE OLSSON: So Mitch,
you like to build stuff.
MITCH HEINRICH: I do.
ISABELLE OLSSON: And you
chose sort of a building.
MITCH HEINRICH: I did.
So I took a little bit
of a different tack
on this question.
I was thinking about it,
and actually a good segue
from Josh.
I was thinking about it more
from a professional standpoint.
And it's actually
more about the tools
that designers are getting,
software tools, that
are allowing us to
do our job in more
interesting and better ways.
So this particular
structure is in Germany,
and it was designed
by algorithm,
and it was fabricated
with CNC robotics.
It's an unsupported structure,
and it fits together
like a puzzle.
So the idea is that
each individual piece
is different from
all the other ones.
They have these
interlocking sections.
And it's an
unsupported structure,
so there's actually no
columns or supports inside.
And I guess it's about 20
feet by 60 feet, or something
like that, so pretty big.
The volume of the thing compared
to the actual structure,
is actually more
impressive than an egg.
So if you think about the shell
of an egg, this is about half
as thin for the same size.
And that just wouldn't
really be possible
if it were a person doing
that design by hand.
So the algorithm figured out
how to puzzle these things
together, and how to
make it work just so.
And I feel like
moving in the future,
designers are going to
have more of these tools
at their disposal.
And complexity kind
of comes for free.
And so it's going to open
some interesting doors for how
we produce things
in the real world.
ISABELLE OLSSON: This reminds
me of an interesting take
on sustainability.
You're creating something
extremely complex
but so lightweight
and so efficient.
How do we think about
that with the new tools
that we have, with 3D
printing, but also having
to create things a
lot faster, perhaps
fueled by how fast software
design development happens.
What's your take on that, Mike?
MIKE SIMONIAN: I
think that there's
a little bit of a challenge
there because especially
if we're talking about
technology products
with accelerating change.
If you think about
Moore's law, and you
think about how quickly
things need to be updated
and how quickly we
have an opportunity
to update things to
be better and better,
we're going to be producing
more and more products that
will get outdated
faster and faster.
And so that goes right up
against sustainability,
in terms of waste.
And I don't have
an answer there.
One approach could be to accept
an object's impermanence, which
could be totally an about face
for where we are now, where we
celebrate how
precious objects are.
Maybe in order to
accept that they're
going to be outdated
really fast, maybe
they should be made out of
materials and processes that
are made to biodegrade.
Just like a milk carton is not
made out of milled aluminum,
because you're going to throw
it out when the milk is gone.
Maybe that's how we should
treat our technology products.
ISABELLE OLSSON:
In your experience,
Victoria, do you
think that's something
that customers will accept?
We've been spoiled with these
polished, beautiful pieces
of metal, objects.
And do you think in the
future people will accept
having a phone made out
of milk carton material?
VICTORIA SLAKER: I
don't know, we actually
might have to mandate that one.
I do think there is
a lot of positives
to the idea of the acceleration.
If you combine the two issues
of, you can have a 3D printer,
or you're changing
the materials.
I think people will accept it
if there's a clear cut benefit.
So you could say,
there's the dark side,
like you're going to 3D
produce a lot of crap.
But you could also say,
well, it might actually
be more efficient
in a lot of ways.
You could have,
instead of everybody
having to put out a small,
medium, and large of a product,
if you're making it at home,
you have an infinite sizing.
You can make it
exactly what you want,
and maybe there will be
less waste because of that.
And that's a benefit.
In terms of whether
or not people are
going to accept the
timelines of hardware,
I think there is
an expectation--
and we talked
about a backstage--
of the merciless
crowds, once they
put their money
into Kickstarter,
they're like, where
the hell's my product?
There's some
education that's going
to have to happen I think.
But there's no doubt that
the direction of the hardware
and software design its just
faster and faster for good
and for bad.
ISABELLE OLSSON: So
talking about speed,
we have representatives
of people
who are in-house
designers in startups,
and from consultancy background.
Where can you actually get
the most done as a designer?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
VICTORIA SLAKER:
Consultancy all the way.
JOSHUA MORENSTEIN: I'm with you.
Consultancy, amazing.
MAAIKE EVERS: I wish I
had a different opinion,
but it is true.
You can get more
done as a consultant.
And you do a lot
more variety of work.
And creatively it's
more interesting.
However, I do feel that as
a designer in an in-house,
there's so much to be done.
Even though it's hard and you're
pushing a boulder up the hill,
there is so much to be
done in corporations.
So I feel like there
is a reason for us
to migrate into that spot
and help them elevate design,
but also just sort of infiltrate
with ideas and with examples
to show how it can actually
be really delightful.
MICHAEL DITULLO:
Just to riff off
of that, like Mike
and Maaike, I've
worked out at
consultancies like Frog,
and I've worked in-house
at companies like Nike.
And both have their
advantages, they're
just a really different.
And I think it depends
on the organization
that you're interacting with.
What I love about
being in-house,
now again, like I liked at
Nike, was having the opportunity
to be a complete
evangelist for design.
And being able to talk
to the board of directors
and say, this is our vision,
this is where we're going,
we need you to believe.
Sometimes you have
the opportunity
to do that as a
consultant as well.
Like I know, Victoria,
you guys interact
a lot with the C suite,
and we talked about that.
And I think it's less about
in-house or consulting
and more about, at
what level are you
engaging with the organization?
So can you get up to the
top, and not only talk
to the decision makers,
but be a decision maker.
And in the role I have now,
it's both a great luxury
and a great risk.
Because it's also nobody's
fault but your own.
And some people
thrive off of that
and some people it's terrifying.
MITCH HEINRICH: So
I'm going to riff off
of that for a second, because I
come from a startup background
before joining Google.
And I think, actually, startups
are the best of everything
in that perspective because
your only limitations are
how much time you
want to put in.
You're owning the full stack,
you're able to do everything.
And budgets can be a
limitation, and just how much
effort you want to put
into it is a limitation.
But in terms of your
ability to execute
on your creative vision, it's
so fulfilling because you just
go for it, and no one
is going to tell you no.
VICTORIA SLAKER: And I think
that's why, maybe, you're
seeing more
consultancies partnering.
Like truly partnering in terms
of taking equity with a startup
because we really
appreciate the idea
that we're wholly invested.
And it is no holds
barred, you really
are having a common goal.
And there's not somebody saying,
OK, well, your initial proposal
was for $100,000, and
you're at $97,000,
and we've got to let you go.
So it's really changed in the
last, probably, 5, 10 years,
it's changed the dynamic.
And we have some of the
benefits of both worlds that way
within some of
the consultancies.
I mean, Josh, you guys
are [INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOSHUA MORENSTEIN: Yeah, my
dad was an industrial designer,
but he went to-- he was
like 1964, I don't know,
they designed drill
presses or something.
And garden shears.
But the role that he
played was so back room.
There was no exposure
to any of the-- I mean,
they still did visionary stuff.
They did beautiful drawings
and had beautiful ideas,
and there were amazing products
that came out of that era,
and eras before that,
and eras since then.
But the role that
the designer played--
or the industrial designer
in this case played--
was more utilitarian
than visionary.
At least that was
where they were
plugged in to the hierarchy.
And I think now it's
very much the case,
and I think we're all
saying the same things.
Whether it's about being
in a startup or in-house,
I think culturally,
designers are
at the very beginning
of the process.
And in the most
successful projects,
they're there at the very, very
end when something comes off
of the line, whatever
that line is.
Whether it's a
manufacturing aspect,
or whether it's
launching an app,
or some other form of software.
So I think that's what it
boils down is our involvement,
and how many times we're allowed
to touch within the process.
ISABELLE OLSSON: So
thinking about the evolution
of the designer, and you
are all design leaders,
you have your own teams.
How should we build
teams for the future?
Is it brand and design?
Is it graphic design?
There's a lot of talk about
how software and hardware
design need to integrate better.
How do you build the ideal
fool proof team for the future?
Mike.
MIKE SIMONIAN: Wow.
I actually think it really
depends on the product.
And I think we need to
really pay attention
to where products are going.
And I kind of see-- if
you break down a product
historically, products always
had some sort of interface--
and whether that's a series
of buttons or a knob--
and there was the
user and the product.
And now there's sort of
three levels of intelligence
that have to go into a product.
There's the user
facing part, there's
the intelligence that the
product has inside of it,
and how it learns.
And then there's
the backside where
there's the over the air
updates, and the company that
makes it, their
side of the product.
So in terms of building a
team to develop products,
I think if we're talking
about products of the future,
I think you're going to need
people that can represent
all of those aspects
of the product,
and design systems,
not products.
MAAIKE EVERS: But just, I think,
as just purely design, how
to create the best culture
for design to live.
I really feel
there's a little bit
of a-- it needs to be
cultivated in a little bit
of a separate entity.
It tends to be
culturally so different
from the technical staff,
and the business staff,
that they almost need a
little bit of a safe haven
to be protected and to let them
be a little odd, and different,
and creative, and have stuff
up, and be messy and be
a little rough, and
let that not confuse
the rest of the company.
So I think there is a need
for a slight separation,
or like a cultivation where
design can do its best,
and can actually bring its
best, and incubate it's best.
ISABELLE OLSSON: Josh, you
just built a new studio,
how are you thinking
about this topic?
JOSHUA MORENSTEIN:
Well, we kind of
build as we go a little bit
because it's a new studio.
We're a little bit
more bootstrap.
But in the past year
and a half, the team's
grown from being just my
partner, Nick, and myself
sitting around, thinking, OK,
now what are we going to do?
Then, of course, the first
folks that we brought in
were industrial designers.
But now we have traditional
graphic design and branding,
and interaction.
When we work on programs--
all of our programs
require some sort of
mechanical engineering.
We, instead of bringing
people like that in-house,
we partner with folks
because we think
that it's better to have
other specialists, people
who bring different culture in.
And I don't know,
we'll see what happens.
At the last studio I
ran, we had more work.
And as the work kept coming
in, we kept building.
But ultimately, it
was really about being
very curatorial about the
types of people we brought in.
They had to be
passionate, they had
to be excited about the work.
And they had to have
taste and experiences.
And not just design
experiences, they
had to have life
experiences because that's
selfishly what gets me excited.
And that's what got
me excited about doing
the programs and
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
ISABELLE OLSSON: Talking
about experience,
what is it that interaction
designers, and software
engineers can learn from the
process of industrial design
and hardware development?
JOSHUA MORENSTEIN: Well, I'm
not going to tell you guys,
but I can tell you.
But the thing that I think
is very, very distinctive
about product design
or industrial design
tangible product is the
permanence that it has.
We create something, and it
takes a certain amount of time.
It's very difficult to compress
it anymore than it has so far.
Maybe 3D printers
will change this.
But in nine months to a
year, something comes out
and it's mass produced,
and there's no changing it,
or it's very, very, very
difficult to change it.
So I think having an
understanding of that.
And I would say, conversely,
a better understanding
from industrial design of
how the digital side happens,
because that's often
changing at the last minute,
and, in the case of Tesla,
could be changed on the fly.
I think that that's the dynamic
that creates something really
interesting, is
that organic nature.
MICHAEL DITULLO:
It's so different.
I mean think of a
pair of Chuck Taylors.
They were designed
100 years ago.
They still sell
two billion dollars
worth of that shoe every year.
What piece of software
is going to be
used in 100 years that's
being made right now?
And so it's such a
different discipline,
but yet there's like a riffing,
and a natural friction that
hopefully is going to
make both of our work
better as our things integrate
more and more and more.
ISABELLE OLSSON:
Mike, is there's
something you've learned from
software engineers and software
development that you felt
affected your process
in a positive way?
MIKE SIMONIAN: Yeah, I think
the initial reaction I had,
working with a lot of
software engineers,
was disbelief at how
they're willing to wait
until improvement
happens naturally.
It's sort of like the hockey
stick mentality of development.
That really surprised me,
because industrial design,
you have the reverse.
You have to establish a
lot up front because you're
about to invest in
tooling, and you
have to have everything
all staged and ready to go.
And then you spend
a lot of time just
making sure that it
achieves that vision.
And I think there's
a balance there,
because I've seen a lot
of software development
where the end result,
features get piled on,
and it's not really predictable.
And then at the end,
if they're really good,
you can get it all together and
ship a really great product.
But I think you could
have a balance there,
where you have a little
bit more vision up front,
and make some really
strong commitments,
but then don't-- the downfall
for hardware is you don't have
the ability to improve
at the last minute.
And I think that's where a lot
of magic happens in software.
Where you're like,
OK, let's try this.
And let's change things right
before it's ready to go out.
ISABELLE OLSSON: So I can
it work better together,
hardware and software,
and atoms and bits,
and kind of coming together
a little bit better.
Anybody?
JOSHUA MORENSTEIN: Maaike?
MAAIKE EVERS: I think
I said it earlier.
I think it's all about having
a good vision to start with.
So if that's there.
And if it's not there,
it needs to be created.
So you have to get a great
synergy between people
to build it.
ISABELLE OLSSON: But
how do you do that?
MAAIKE EVERS: How
do you do that.
Trust.
Developing a lot of trust, and
great respect for teammates.
And building up on their
strengths to get to
carve out that best nugget
that everything holds on to.
MITCH HEINRICH: To tie
two of your questions
together, Isabelle, I think
the team building aspect
and what you look for also
ties into this question.
My approach has been to
build teams of hybrids, so
people who can speak
multiple languages, hardware
and the software.
I think that being able
to connect with your peers
on that same level, and to be
able to speak intelligently
about what they have
on their plate as well
as your specific craft is
super important to maintaining
product fidelity, and
achieving a vision.
ISABELLE OLSSON:
What's your advice?
MICHAEL DITULLO: I think
that the key for us
is to just have one team.
To not have a hardware team,
and to not have a software team.
But to have one team that's
bonded to a single vision,
and working together,
and software people
involved really early on.
Like giving feedback
to the hardware.
And hardware people
involved all the way
to the last software
launch, giving feedback
on the software.
And we have the distinctions
in the disciplines on the team,
but it's one team.
And I think that's, to me,
that the best way to do it.
MIKE SIMONIAN: Going back to the
idea of hardware and software
interaction, and
how they influence
each other, especially when you
project forward into the future
and you think about all of the
traditions of building objects.
I think they're all
going to get redefined.
And I think the hardware
development process
is going to look
closer to the software.
It's going to look more
like software development.
And I think that's a
really a big opportunity
for both industrial designers
and interaction designers.
As we both admit that
we're creating experiences.
And I think I see a lot
of interaction designers
that are super interested
in industrial design,
especially more and more lately.
And I think that
interaction is going
to not be relegated
to the screen
as it has been in the past.
I just love to look forward
to that mixing more and more
as hardware processes
become more flexible.
ISABELLE OLSSON: Please
come and get us afterwards
if you have any
questions one on one.
And hopefully you have
a great rest of the day.
Thank you so much.